Hungary is threatening to block the latest
round of Russian sanctions and EU aid for Ukraine
if Ukraine doesn t take a Hungarian bank
its war sponsor list.
Hungary's foreign minister issued the threat
after Ukraine added OTP Bank to its blacklist
for refusing to pull out of Russia
and refusing to comply with a law aimed specifically
at the pro Russian regimes in occupied eastern Ukraine.
The foreign minister previously stated that
placing it on the list of international sponsors of war
is unacceptable and scandalous,
and that OTP has not violated any international laws.
Its operations
fully comply with all kinds of expectations
and legislation.
Frustration is growing within the EU over Hungary
stands, but OTP is not the only business
from western nations on the blacklist,
which includes some notable companies
like Procter and Gamble.
Hungary has refused to donate
any equipment to its neighbour to the east
and has criticised EU sanctions against Russia.